what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder where we talk all
things marvel and mcu i'm your host
warren thompson and as we've been
talking about lately the mcu is getting
very very exciting and the future is
very very bright but i believe that the
mcu is about to change in a very big way
and in a way it's going to have its very
own reset now i'm not talking about them
resetting everything that's already
happened in the mcu as in get rid of
iron man captain america the whole get
rid of all of those stories that's not
gonna happen in fact many of you have
asked me if i think that that ever will
happen and i don't think so if it ever
did it would have to be years and years
and years down the line and they would
have to take a break before resetting it
and i don't think that's gonna happen
and i don't think it's necessary however
i believe after phase six the mcu will
do its own type of reset where they keep
everything that's happened but basically
start new at least have a new focus and
that focus is going to center around the
x-men we'll deep dive into it but
before we get started big thank you to
established titles for sponsoring this
video this one's actually really cool
and very personal to me because i've
actually used established titles before
my family is from scotland and they do a
lot of great work for the environment
with established titles you can
officially become a lord or a lady and
when i say that i literally mean it you
can change your name to lord or lady and
get it on your credit cards or plane
tickets and you get an official
certificate here's mine in scotland if
you own a piece of land you are referred
to as lord or lady through established
titles you get one square foot of land
in scotland which officially makes you a
lord or a lady and you get a certificate
with your unique plot number where you
can see the exact location of your land
and the best part is they actually plant
a tree with every order this makes a
perfect last minute gift for somebody a
loved one or a friend and established
titles is actually running a big labor
day sale right now plus if you use the
code cosmic wonder you get an additional
10 off so go to establishtitles.com
cosmic wonder to get your gifts now and
help support the channel and establish
titles told me that the first 200 people
purchasing a title pack using my link
will effectively be next to my plot
within a few minutes of walking distance
depending on how many of you want to
become a lord or a lady we can build our
own little cosmic wonder kingdom now
disney's d23 expo is coming up in about
a week now and of course we're all super
hyped for it because there's the
possibility that they could be revealing
some projects that revolve around the
mutants and while i definitely think
that they need to introduce at least
some mutants before secret wars i think
the mutants are really going to be
coming after secret wars in fact i think
the entire next saga phase 7 phase 8
phase 9 is going to be the mutants saga
i called that in a previous video but
i'm calling it again right now and if
marvel is going to do what i think
they're about to do the avengers kind of
won't be prominent figures in the mcu
anymore but it's really going to be all
about the x-men and the fantastic four
now the infinity saga was awesome it was
the best it was fantastic and the
multiversal saga is going pretty well
some people have some issues with it but
we've gotten a lot of great projects
from it and of course we still have
phase 5 and phase 6 to play out before
this saga is over but before this saga
ends i think it's going to set up the
groundwork for the next phase obviously
and i think that they're going to do
that with the x-men because they're
going to build the x-men team and i'm
assuming that they're going to do that
much like they did the avengers team and
this is where it kind of resets because
i think marvel and kevin feige actually
wants to build the x-men much like they
did the avengers team in the beginning
and what i mean by that is have
individual solo movies that kind of
connect with other movies until they
eventually all have to come together to
fight some big great cause and when i
think about this i think it makes the
most sense and i actually think it could
be one of the most exciting ways to do
it especially since we know that kevin
feige doesn't like to do things the way
things have been done before a perfect
example of this is spider-man when
captain america civil war introduced
spider-man we did not get really a
traditional origin story they didn't
dive into it too much but we didn't get
the uncle ben story we thought we were
going to get it in spider-man homecoming
but we still didn't and honestly we
never really got anything about uncle
ben in the spider-man homecoming trilogy
except for the briefcase that had his
initials on it but basically aunt may
was our uncle ben of the spider-man
homecoming trilogy that is a perfect
example of kevin feige kind of wanting
to do things a little bit differently
and i think that will remain true for
the x-men especially since kevin feige
himself worked on the x-men films the
original ones at least now the x-men
have kind of been done in two different
ways so far the first way that was done
in the first x-men movie that we got was
that the x-men team was already
established then we went to the newer
x-men movies where we got the backstory
of magneto and professor xavier we watch
them come together and then we watch
them form the x-men team then of course
we watch magneto break away with half of
the mutants now since kevin feige is
most likely going to want to do things a
little bit differently i think that it's
going to be a combination of the two and
i think this is how phase seven is going
to start off i think that in the end of
phase six and in secret wars we'll get a
big setup for the x-men so the team will
kind of be established but then in phase
seven we'll start with our individual
movies i think there will be a
relatively small x-men team established
in the mcu i think most of the x-men
that we might get in secret wars could
be variants could be from other
universes possibly the fox universe a
recent rumor going around is that when
deadpool enters the mcu he is going to
bring some of the fox x-men with him and
they will have somewhat of a role to
play in secret wars that would establish
the x-men team that would show us hey
the x-men do exist and it would tell the
people in our universe hey they probably
exist somewhere here as well so phase 7
could start with individual films like a
cyclops film like a rogue film they
could possibly do a wolverine solo film
however i think they might stay away
from that for a little bit but i think
during this time we're going to see
professor x recruit x-men i think
professor x is going to have already
established somewhat of an x-men team
over at the x-men mansion and at the
start of phase 7 we'll start to see the
recruitment process and the way marvel
studios has set this up is actually
quite clever what they did in miss
marvel sets up the individual films in
the future they essentially established
that some people have the ex-gene
however they need something to awaken it
this was the bangle for kamala khan it
also seems like they're kind of
retconning the scarlet witch to actually
be a mutant although she is a powerful
witch she could also have the mutant
gene that was activated by the infinity
stone so some of the x-men could already
exist and their mutant powers already be
activated but we could also see new
mutants powers get activated and these
could be our solo films until eventually
they come together for a big x-men film
much like the avengers came together for
the first avengers film now from here on
out it's going to get pretty cool
because they're not just going to
completely get rid of all of the other
characters that existed before phase 7.
so we'll still have the scarlet witch
there some of the avengers are still
going to be there hopefully spider-man
is still going to be there but the
fantastic four are also going to be
coming into the picture as well so
they're going to be blended in with the
x-men 2. and i believe that these two
groups are sort of going to be the main
focus of the mcu moving forward starting
with phase 7. until eventually we have a
huge movie like avengers infinity war
that brings not only the x-men and the
fantastic four together but of course
also the avengers together and the new
guardians team as well basically this is
how i think it's going to go down phase
7 starts off with some individual mutant
projects then we're going to get another
fantastic four film that could be in
phase 8 depending on what their timeline
is also during phase 7 we will get our
other little projects as well that'll
kind of show us the side stories of some
new avengers possibly the young avengers
and some of the new characters that are
being introduced then i think we'll be
getting our first official x-men film
after that they'll continue to do
individual x-men movies but we'll start
to see the actual x-men group interact
with people like reed richards in the
fantastic four and also of course the
avengers now these will be brief
interactions and we may see some movies
and some projects where we see a couple
members of different teams interact with
each other but not the full full-on
teams interacting and fighting with each
other to try to save earth or the
universe as a whole basically it has to
build you can't just throw everyone
together all at once then there's no
climax there's nothing exciting left to
see so that's why i think marvel studios
has to start off with these individual
mutant projects build them up into the
first x-men team then continue
recruiting and introducing new x-men
members all the while having them
interact with some members of the
avengers and the fantastic four until
eventually i think all of them are going
to have to come together to fight
galactus if we're talking about big bads
the one that's on the table that's
probably not going to be used in the
multiversal saga is galactus and what
better villain to bring together the
x-men the fantastic four and the
avengers so i really think that after
phase six phase seven is going to kick
off another amazing saga which again i
believe is going to be the mutant saga
that will focus on the mutants and the
fantastic four but of course have the
avengers there as well and to end this
saga we'll see all of the teams come
together and honestly if this happens
even remotely close to how i think it's
going to happen it'll probably be the
best saga marvel had to focus on the
avengers for years and years and years
because they didn't have the rights to
the x-men or the fantastic four but now
that they do they can kind of switch the
focus and give the avengers a little bit
of a break so the shift of the main
focus of the mcu would go from the
avengers to the x-men and the fantastic
four and i think that this is going to
make a heck of a saga but let me know
your thoughts about this in the comments
down below please don't forget to like
the video and subscribe to stay up to
date on all things relating to the mcu
for live updates you can follow me on
instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof